[Music]
do you know anything about wine a little
you're a lightsaber i'm chris
skye
two sudden adventures it's a sudden
adventure
[Music]
shame
hey get away from my car man we don't
want any problems
wait wait wait wait wait
ladies you're two weeks behind on the
rent again you're not gonna say anything
explain where you were all night
i saw something on the news lisa it's
your roommate
scotty should probably contact the
police that would be stupid of me why
expecting a package
how's the knee dude i do good work don't
i
everything goes loverboy
stripping me down to the stuff
oh this was
now you're catching on
screen you are a very naughty girl
that's scary right i need all your
passwords and security codes
what's your mother's day today
mother's maiden name
are you going to get chris so you want
me to call the police he's right here
what do they want
okay you're okay
my name is christopher decker there's a
woman in my house she's imprisoned me
against my will she's trying to steal my
identity she wants to kill me
thank god you came back chris thought i
might lose you forever all better now
you should have seen a look on your face
[Music]
stay back
afraid of the dark
i love the dark
[Music]
you